this is all the interesting one
yeah yeah this one is a bit difficult
yeah
so I'm going to show you some puzzles
you're going to have 10 seconds to look
at the tablet and then I'm going to take
the tablet away and you're going to have
to give me the solution okay you ready
sure all right
made in five wait a minute
okay
you got it all right yeah 26 out of six
division
very nice very nice very nice good start
okay
level six yes Queen G6 97 95.
no wait
where's
if you go 97 I go King h8
which page five
yeah that's
that's not working out
okay Queen G6 has to be the right first
move yes
um oh Bishop 906 Bishop okay so that's
right yes very good
okay
so it's Queen takes G6
fg97 check pH 7.8 Bishop f8
and then Bishop H3 H5
uh
wait Bishop S5 must be black and
official history Bishop H5 the Knight G5
Aha and then 19 G6 is that iPhone
uh so you said Queen takes G6 after hd6
97 okay we have Knight F6 here oh Knight
F6 King h8 oh that's Bishop f8 yes
Bishop G7
right
let's see
um 97 King H7 Bishop f8
Bishop H5 Bishop H5 95 wait do I have a
knight on G3 yeah F3 you do have an
iPhone
so what if I go King h8 first instead of
King H7
yeah
yeah yeah
okay yeah
that is still plenty of options and
opportunities left all right next one
you ready yes let's do it asparian study
why to move
okay I know you know it it's not fair
when a three year old could be true
casparian study yes
looks kind of familiar
but
okay yeah Rook D2 repeat
so how do you start Queen A3 rookie two
rookie two d206 A3 it would be two okay
very nice very nice
well done
okay
so it's Queen A3 check A2
and Rook B2 group A3 Rook B2 of M3 V1
very nice yeah very nice yes
impressive knowledge
another study I mean if you know this
one
impressed why to move okay that's all I
don't know
so it's 10 seconds as well 10 seconds oh
foreign
H4 H4 uh
now I have to yes you can get five and
H5 and King E4 yeah very nice
as king E4 the final move Bishop B6
Queen B6 C5 Queen B8 B6 Queen C8 King D4
yes H4 and king of five H5 and King E4
TV four back yeah very nice
well done okay this one is a bit
difficult
so I guess we should text B6 yes Queen
B6
C5 yes Queen ba
B6 you can see a C7
Queen B7
uh C7 might not be correct oh
oh okay yes yes H4
sure
you have apology three H5 and H6 right
yes okay
exactly yeah very nice yeah that's the
one yes yeah
foreign
all right this one just tell me as long
as I'm doing better than Fabian are you
you're doing better yes yes
that's that spirited rivalry
um why to play and draw
so wait it's Rook on F2 or Rook on C7
yeah this is confusing
okay
so let's see okay
B6 I'm not sure what is flex response
here E6 I go uh Rook to D3 check okay
okay King E5 E3
look C4 E2
oh
I missed something but this is correct
this is you're on the right track yes I
have to do something correct yeah
oh these ones are tough man
these ones are tough
rookie four before you take on G4 or
after
and do before before okay before I think
I can go okay E7
oh no yeah yeah I forgot E8 you can take
on e4 so you have take on G4
and maybe another check no
if you got another another checkup yes
so I have to go rookie four okay three
Rook text E3 A7 E1 and then King is
correct King before check King B7 King
D7 yeah yeah
seven yeah exactly yeah very nice so
that's very nice yeah
must be E6 E6 yes Rook D3 check Rook
this three
uh
174 yeah
okay King E5 B3 uh Rook C4 E2
um is Rook G4 rookie four rookie three
text takes E7
very nice
king before King this is
very nice well done
okay so E6 you give a check
can you find me play E3 I take you play
E2 that's right rookie four
all right I can also
okay rookie for you plug King F2
E7 you green
um
so that wins for black right yeah
there's better ways in the in the middle
let me see the starting position yes
okay five more seconds
a653
give me five eight three at least four
and E3
okay so I can type gf2 and rookie four
rookie three and you have to play rookie
three
and uh
weird position
do I have anything better than taking E7
e131 Queen yes
um
happens not be losing
I was King E6 will draw King and if I go
King before yeah and I go to either side
to D7 and if I go to F4 he goes left
okay yeah very nice
yes yes
why to play and draw
oh but this this I'm pretty sure I've
seen
this looks so familiar
so he has to go to either H2 H3 I
haven't been able to decide this one but
my 10 seconds pass fast yes yes yes my
feeling would be
definitely not H2 because each student
maybe eat one night that's a really good
problem yes so I have to go to H3 H3
Knight F4 HP H2 my G4 check energy punch
check then kh1 Knight F2 check okay H2
E1 Knight and Knight F3 Knight F3 King
G3 yes very nice
very good
I know this one I'm just trying to
remember
so it's one of the three nice with
except King H3 Knight F4 Knight or uh
King H2 Knight G4 Chuck Knight D4 King
H1
yeah very good
um okay let's
start with King H2
Knight F3
well yes but King history I will go
Knight F4 okay now I have to go to H2
Knight G4
okay now I have to go to H1 Knight F2
can actually engage two E1 light
and uh
92.
oh negative three negative three King G3
yeah yeah Knight F3 Knight takes a three
King G3 very nice
I knew this one I was just trying to
remember the whole detail look you're
the only one that's uh remaining perfect
after
five studies last one why to move
no I've seen this one okay this one I
think I've seen before Queen G7 look at
seven Knight six easy yes very nice yes
but what's the uh what's the puzzle why
to move
was you you save the simplest one for
the last one this this is
yes yes
wow
yes that's it we saved the easiest for
Less
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]